a US prosecutor accuses Britain's Prince
Andrew of providing zero cooperation in
Jeffrey Epstein sex trafficking case the
second son of queen elizabeth ii said in
november he would be willing to help
with the investigation but yesterday the
federal prosecutor called out the prince
for ignoring their request to me
virginia Jeff ray claims Epstein
pressured her to have sex with Andrew
the Prince denies it in a damning
interview last year Andrew admitted he's
been to Epstein's private island in the
Caribbean who reported on that island
last week authorities say Epstein used
it to trap girls and young women it was
one of the only positive things that
came out of that disastrous BBC
interview was that he said of course I'm
willing to help any appropriate law
enforcement agency with their
investigations if required but
apparently not but now it's crickets
because they even used a phrase zero car
zero very unusual for the US Attorney to
pick not to comment on that indeed